Between flubbed lines and technical difficulties,
fans have gotten to see the cast of Breaking Bad's
true colors — and a surprising amount of sexuality
— through the show's official blooper reels.
Breaking Bad fans will never forget the fallout
from Hank's fateful trip to the bathroom, where
he finally realizes Heisbenberg's true identity.
When the second part of Season 5 debuted, Hank,
played by Dean Norris, wastes no time
confronting Walt about his double life.
While the tense standoff between
Hank and Walt is unforgettable,
you might not know that to get
this über-serious moment right,
the Breaking Bad crew had to overcome
some pretty hilarious technical issues.
In the bloopers for the second half of Season
5, we see the attempts at this scene gone wrong.
At the moment when Hank pushes the button to
threateningly close the garage door, it repeatedly
gets stuck. Norris keeps jamming the button to
try and get the door to shut but to no avail.
At one point, Norris gives up and drops
the garage door remote on the table to
end a take before dramatically falling over.
Unfortunately, by that point, neither actor
seemed to be able to keep it together to
get through a take without cracking up.
This blooper is a Bryan Cranston classic and
one of the rare hilarious moments that came
from the actor staying in character rather
than breaking it. In this Season 4 outtake,
the filmmakers were trying to capture a
low-angle shot of Walt sticking a bill
into a vending machine. It's a small shot you
probably don't remember, but when Cranston
can't quite seem to get the machine to take
the dollar, an unforgettable moment erupts.
In the take, Cranston feeds the bill
into the machine multiple times,
only for it to be spat back out at the actor.
After the machine repeatedly rejects him,
Cranston, still in character, mutters
a certain name under his breath.
"Bogdan."
The man he's referring to is the
original owner of the carwash.
Since Walt and Bogdan have never had
a particularly friendly relationship,
it's no surprise that Walt would blame Bogdan for
not keeping his vending machines in working order.
In a characteristically manipulative
moment from Season 2, Walt hypes Jesse
up by likening him to a blowfish. In his defense,
it's an apt metaphor. As Walter says, both
Jesse and the blowfish start out unassuming.
"Small in stature, not swift, not
cunning. Easy prey for predators."
The point of this comparison was to highlight
Jesse's ability to intimidate others when he
needs to, even if he appears weak
on the outside. The speech works,
and Jesse is noticeably more energized for the
rest of the scene. However, in the Breaking Bad
Season 2 bloopers, we see what happens when
Bryan Cranston can't quite nail the line.
The final line of the speech is the rhetorical
question, "Who messes with the blowfish,
Jesse?" In the outtakes, Cranston slips up
by repeatedly calling Jesse the wrong name.
"Who messes with the blowfish, Jeff?"
If you're wondering who Jeff could possibly
be, even Cranston himself doesn't know. As
the blooper continues, we see him rack his
brain to try and figure out just where that
came from. We may never know the answer, but we
are thankful for this famous flub regardless.
This behind-the-scenes moment shows us the light
side of Breaking Bad star Anna Gunn. While Skyler
White was pretty much all business all the
time during Gunn's scenes on the drama, it's
clear from this Season 2 blooper that the actress
who played her has a much better sense of humor.
In this series of clips, we see Gunn
on set holding a prosthetic hand. As
she feels herself up with the hand, the
actress jokingly moans Tuco's name before
throwing her head back and cackling
at the absurdity of what she is doing.
Bryan Cranston and Aaron Paul
got very close throughout the
shooting of Breaking Bad. So close, in fact,
that their friendship has extended well into
the decade since the series's last season aired.
Paul and Cranston's chemistry both on and off
screen was so natural that Jesse's original fate
was even written out of the show to keep him on
as a main character. However, if you haven't seen
this particular outtake, you might not realize
just how close the two were. For as close as
the two were emotionally, some viewers might be
surprised how close they've gotten physically.
In this Breaking Bad Season 2 blooper,
the actors who play Walt and Jesse have an
intimate moment of male bonding. In this clip,
the two are embracing when Paul reaches for
Cranston's butt and starts to rub his co-star.
The actors start to verbally flirt
with one another while they strip
off their hazard suits. This sensual
moment might change the way you look
at Walt and Jesse's relationship the
next time you rewatch Breaking Bad.
When most viewers think of Breaking Bad,
they think of one iconically menacing
line spoken by Walter White in Season 4.
"I am not in danger, Skyler, I am the danger."
As legendary as this scene is, Cranston and
Gunn didn't get it on every take. Thankfully,
the showrunners included some of the mishaps
from this scene in the Season 4 blooper reel.
In this clip, Gunn tees Cranston up perfectly,
delivering her line about Walt being "in danger"
with absolute sincerity. The response starts
as a smile, but before Cranston can break into
the main part of his speech, he starts
laughing uncontrollably. Something about
the moment was just too much for Cranston.
We all laugh in uncomfortable situations,
but there's something particularly bizarre
about seeing Walter White break in that moment.
In one of the most outlandish moments of his
entire career, Bryan Cranston let it all loose
while filming a shower scene for Breaking Bad
Season 4. In addition to being completely naked
and in the middle of shaving his head, this
blooper depicts the disrobed Cranston singing
a SpongeBob SquarePants theme song parody. While
waiting for the showrunners to get the right shot,
Cranston chooses to adopt a pirate
accent before singing to himself.
"Who works naked with the light meter?"
The answer is not entirely clear, although
you can definitely make out that whoever
this shanty is about is known for their,
quote, "sweaty balls." As he continues,
he backs up into the frame, where, if not
for the mercy of the editors, viewers would
have become even more intimately familiar with
Cranston's body than the Pilot episode allows.
We've already seen how, in the face of technical
difficulties, Brian Cranston can improvise silly
contributions to scenes that still make some
sense in the context of the show. However,
his interaction with Gus Fring actor
Giancarlo Esposito is anything but sensible.
In this outtake from Breaking Bad Season 4, Bryan
Cranston improvises between takes by ordering a
meal at the register while Esposito takes his
order. While a tense conversation should be
transpiring in these moments, Cranston just
keeps telling Esposito his order. In the end,
Cranston tells him, in a top-tier
deadpan, about his dietary restrictions.
"No, no. I'm allergic to tacos."
In the lab where they cook meth, Walt and Jesse
are often seen transporting large plastic boxes
and barrels filled with various chemicals.
Occasionally, these barrels have been filled
with bodies dissolving in acid. Having disposed of
a body by doing the same thing early in Season 1,
it seems the pair have just gotten used
to this morbid occupational hazard.
This aspect of their job adds a stark
contrast to this Season 4 blooper,
where Cranston and Paul are seen playing
with an empty one of these barrels.
The clip begins with Cranston holding a large
plastic barrel by the lid and slamming it on
the floor in an attempt to open the top.
Paul comes in to start pounding on it,
then Cranston gives it a large kick.
It's not the most outstanding of the
Season 4 bloopers but it does provide a
unique look behind the show's curtain.
This blooper comes off like Bryan Cranston
doing a comedy sketch. In the same vein as
his shower song, we weren't quite
sure what the actor was on that day
but we appreciate his improvisational
antics even more this time around.
In this clip from the third Season
4 blooper reel, Cranston delivers a
satire of a PSA directly to the camera. What
is it for? Anal bleaching, as it turns out.
"From the cast to the crew: an anal bleaching kit.
Because no crew should walk
around with a dark anus."
Walt and Skyler's marital life has always
been complicated, to say the least. Between
the constant power struggle, the lies, and
the cheating, it's far from a typical married
relationship. Even so, some elements of their
romantic life remained a mystery to the audience
throughout the run of the series — at least
until the Season 4 blooper reels came out.
In this outtake from Season 4, Bryan Cranston
walks up to Anna Gunn while clothed in a baby
costume, diaper and all, before taking
a pacifier out of his mouth to speak.
"I know it was my fantasy, but
I hope you got some enjoyment."
Gunn laughs and cheekily calls Cranston a "good
boy" before giving her co-star a playful spank.
In the final season of Breaking Bad, audiences saw
the long-awaited return of some characters that
had been out of focus for several seasons.
In one scene, we see Jesse's old friends,
Badger and Skinny Pete, up to their old nonsense
while running an errand for Jesse and Walt.
This time, we see them messing around with
the instruments in a music store. As Badger,
played by Matt Jones, hammers away on
the guitar to no avail, we see Pete,
played by Charles Baker, turn out a
nice classical melody on the piano.
While these events might already sound
familiar to those who have seen the show,
this Season 5 blooper shows a longer clip,
featuring an extended piano solo by Skinny Pete.
Baker continues his classical demonstration
long after Jones stops strumming and the
take ends. As he plays, Jones looks on in
frustration until Baker finishes his moment.
"Yeah, we get it, you're better."